could everyone tell me what is the ideal
breast size like one that you could at
least like hold in the palm of your hand
I think that is a decent size yeah I
agree yeah I feel like a c is a good one
yeah
more yeah or you could leave it down and
they're chilling
do any of you amazing ladies uh name
your boobs
mine have to do with the size so okay
gotcha what's everyone's like go-to
style of bra that they wear I honestly
only ever really wear sports bras or
like bralettes
um I'm just not an underwire girly like
I just I find them so uncomfortable to
wear like a full-on bra gosh I I can
only find like select Styles so like the
only things I can find are like the
balcony type bras and they all have the
wire and I need the wire so who doesn't
like to wear bras me me Destiny I think
maybe a clarifying question is like if
you have to leave your home do you like
to wear your bra or not comfortable
without a bra out in public or no no no
no
I'm okay without it uh to be honest with
you because I go to Mexico and it's more
free so you can not care about what
people say so I do go out to my Rancho
and stuff without a bra I think it
depends on the way that people look at
you like I think it's not bad to look
it's bad to stay you should probably
come over to this side I think she
should be yeah I yeah like the first
yeah
can anyone suck their own nipples
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay I think I'm that Bridget
hey a niece all down here also not on my
resume you can suck on your own nipple
and knees yeah I think you should
probably go a little bit I don't know
where I'm going so do we feel like the
two that could suck their own nipples
they should probably be like all the way
over there or yeah could everyone
tell me what in their mind is the ideal
breast size
I feel like
um
like one that you could at least like
hold in the palm of your hand I think
that is a decent size yeah I agree yeah
I feel like a c is a good one yeah
more yeah or you could leave it down and
they're chilling has anyone ever
considered surgery 100 yes a thousand
percent every day right I've actually
had surgery already do you regret it or
are you happy you made that choice so I
actually got it done at Tijuana in
Mexico
um with I'm guessing not board certified
surgeon I don't necessarily regret it I
just wish I had gone with a better
surgeon I know that like a lot of
influence comes from societal standards
um but I think ultimately you can always
talk to your doctors about you know what
would be the best decision for you but
if you have the money and the time and
you can do it like do whatever is going
to make you happy I feel like you should
probably move over there then a little
bit okay and then if you went to Tijuana
I'm gonna guess it was probably to go
get bigger yeah so how old were you guys
when you guys got your you started
getting like breasts and having to start
like late eighth grade third fourth
grade I want to say honestly like 17. I
feel like for me like when my breath
started growing that's was like when I
started to become a woman and I don't
know I just feel like that was a big
transition price kind of when you get
your period for the first time I feel
like people who were like uh later
Bloomers might be like a little more
towards the right yeah I agree yeah I
agree I think you want to sweat yeah we
should switch okay okay
I think you should go a little bit more
over there okay I'm going to bring you
this way any back issues
yes back pain yes yes lower back yeah I
get tension headaches by the end of the
day I think a lot of it is linked to my
bra I do have like the whole back pain
and like trap pain situation but I don't
get the tension headaches so I feel like
that's should be more this way
what do you guys feel is more likable
from like
society's viewpoint
I think Society tends to favor larger
breasts
whether it's like the Hollywood like
blonde bombshell situation or whether
it's like a more cultural perspective or
like latinas are expected to be like
curvaceous it's usually
large breasts yeah that's what they go
for I agree for me when men try to put
their opinion on breast size it makes me
want to change who I am to be something
that they don't like because I feel like
they sexualize breasts so much that it
makes me just want to run in the
opposite direction of what they want
yeah growing up in high school and
Junior High it was like so awful for
like guys to like backhand compliment
you know when they're like oh like it's
okay you don't have this or you have
this that's better that was always
frustrating when guys would compliment
you but also like completely offend you
I've lived in America but I also used to
spend my entire summers in Japan and the
societal expectations specifically from
straight men that judge women are so
different everybody over there the
expectation is to have like smaller
breasts whereas in America I feel like a
lot of people think that you have to
have large breasts how does everyone
feel I feel like we're good yeah I'm
good with this
[Music]
so I'm a professional profiter I've been
doing it for just over a year and
basically there's two measurements
there's an underbust measurement and
there's an overbust measurement so you
take them tape measure you'll measure
around your underbust that number if
it's even take that number if it's odd
round up to an even number then you'll
take your overbust number and each inch
of difference between your underbust and
your overbust is a cup size so for
example I measure 40 around and 45 over
five inches of difference is a b c d e
so I'm a 40 E
foreign
Cameron
it is what it is
sixth Lupe okay
[Music]
I was surprised by Lupe just the
personality was just so great and
infectious I don't know I like the big
boobs you have to have a little bit of
confidence in here fifth Maya fourth
destiny
third Amanda
second Bridget
and first anise
I remember talking to my Grandma about
what I was going to be doing this
weekend and my little cousin heard the
conversation and I heard him talking to
his mom on FaceTime she was like she's
gonna do a booby video I think she's
gonna win
say you're you're bus size 32b
I'm 38c so 28 f
30 f
30g
42 G
31 I
I think I threw them off because I was
all the way over there and I'm
definitely not there I do believe it has
to do a lot with the attitude that you
bring to yourself I have a breast size
that it's particularly seen as really
small and not very appealing because
I've always been a big girl and my
breasts don't match my body so it's so
it has been an issue but I think it's
more the way that I carry myself
so who was the one who got breast
surgery
so you got them larger yes I got them I
had some Rush tissue prior and then I
lost weight and then I lost my boobs and
then I got them there but I just wish I
went to a better surgeon that's all yeah
no but they look nice though thank you I
appreciate that did anyone have a
different idea of what their breast size
was before they just got measured
I thought it was a double D but I was a
g yeah I thought it was a 40 E but I'm a
42 G I think I'm an a honestly do you
guys know what the national average
breast size is no it's a 34 double D
what
yeah
is it bigger than you guys thought it
would be or small yes D it's the cup
it's the whole thing half the stores
don't sell that size in store like
that's crazy like we all have we all
have boobs like why why is it so taboo
that like women have cleavage and large
breasts if you have big boobs and you
love them that's awesome if they cause
you health issues and you want to change
them that's also awesome if you have
small tits get poof skincares yay boobs
keep an eye on it for me though because
they have a mind of Their Own
no